TONI THOMPSON: I'd like to
introduce to you, my guests.
This is Dan Cohen.
Dan Cohen is the
founder of a program
called Music and Memory.
And music and memory is what
this wonderful documentary
is about.
The documentary is
called "Alive Inside".
And we have, also, Michael
Rossato-Bennett, too enliven
our conversation.
So welcome.
DAN COHEN: Great.
TONI THOMPSON:
Welcome both of you.
I'd like to start by talking
with Dan a little bit,
and find out what was the
genesis of this program?
How did you get this
whole thing started?
DAN COHEN: So I'm
a social worker.
But I have, actually, a career
in technology companies.
And in 2006, on the
radio, a journalist
was talking about how
iPods are ubiquitous.
They're everywhere.
And I thought, well, young
people all have them,
many of us older adults.
But if you're in a
nursing home, it just
didn't seem to be
a true statement.
And so I googled iPods
and nursing homes.
And even though there's 16,000
nursing homes in the US,
I couldn't find one that was
providing people's own music
to the residents of these homes.
And so I called up a local home.
I live on Long Island-- a
600-bed county facility--
and I said, I know music's
already your number one
recreational activity.
But can we see if
there's any added
value if we were to totally
personalize the music for them?
They said, sure.
And I came in with my
laptop and some iPods.
And it was just an instant
and definitive hit.
TONI THOMPSON: Wonderful.
Now, did you have any
relationship with the nursing
home previously?
Did you just call them
up, out of the blue?
DAN COHEN: No.
Just called out of the blue.
Yeah.
TONI THOMPSON: That's wonderful.
And what happened?
DAN COHEN: So I would come
in every couple of weeks.
I wouldn't just say, oh,
here's the music that you said
or pretty much the
artist that you said.
Because so much of the music
that I was going to give them,
I knew would be
sort of so-so music.
We're all used to listening
to so-so music on the radio.
How often do you go
from station to station,
trying to figure that out?
And that's why we're
all very specific.
We can listen to
whatever we want to,
however long we want to.
So I hung the list over time.
So every couple
weeks I'd come back
and get rid of the so-so music.
So that after two
or three months,
every song of the 100,
200, 300-song playlist
was a song that
resonated with them.
Or got them more upbeat,
or helped calm them down
if they were agitated.
TONI THOMPSON: Wow.
So it really is personalized
to quite a serious degree.
DAN COHEN: It's
totally personalized.
I mean, there's already plenty
of music that's by genre.
Oh, they're 83,
give them Big Band.
Well, no.
Just to all the
Googlers, if anybody
thinks of their favorite
genre music of music,
if you were to say
your genre of music
and then have somebody else
guess your favorite musicians
or songs, you know, they're not
going to be able to do that.
And so right now, best
practice is giving people
music they don't really
necessarily love.
And so we're changing
that by using
the same digital music
culling and honing
that we all have access to.
We kind of forget
about our elders,
thinking, oh, they never
liked computers and stuff.
They won't like this
stuff with the music,
because it involves devices.
And our approach is just
tell us what you like.
We'll figure out what
you like, and here it is.
And we'll take care of the tech.
TONI THOMPSON: That's
a really good point.
The technology is
fearsome for some people.
And yet, here you are,
with your little device,
your little iPod.
And it turns into
a source of joy.
DAN COHEN: Yeah,
it's pretty amazing.
TONI THOMPSON: That's exciting.
So where did you go from there?
I understand now you've got
this wonderful program that's
in many nursing homes.
Tell us about that.
DAN COHEN: So the
program is now running
in every state in the US and
a number of other countries,
in 2,800 facilities--
nursing homes,
assisted-living facilities,
hospitals, hospices,
home-care programs,
and adult-day programs.
It's wherever elders are being
served, and for elders at home.
Because we have materials for
people who are at home, to help
them do this themselves.
And so in 15 states it's
become a public policy
to have Music and Memory, that
every person in a nursing home
should have their own music.
And so our goal is to scale
this so every state has that,
and everybody has access.
TONI THOMPSON: That's wonderful.
Now, you talked about
other countries.
Tell me a bit about
that, if you would.
DAN COHEN: Sure.
When the Henry video went viral,
it just fantastically just hit
the right chord, so to speak.
I think it hit the right
chord because people are very
frustrated that there is nothing
you can do about Alzheimer's.
Alzheimer's is a
terminal disease.
And what was the question again?
TONI THOMPSON: The
other countries.
DAN COHEN: The other
countries, I'm sorry.
So when it went viral, I
got feedback from emails,
from all over the world.
And many people said, I
want to get this going here.
So it's now running in Australia
and South Africa, in Israel,
in Holland and the
UK, and Denmark.
And many other countries
are interested as well.
TONI THOMPSON: That
is so exciting.
You must be really
gratified to have that.
DAN COHEN: It's great.
But the challenge is
out of every 100 persons
in a nursing homes, 98 of
them are sitting idle right.
So that's the fact that
time and motion studies
show that that 90% of
people in nursing homes
are actually idle, and
half the people in homes
never ever get a visitor.
So if you're in a nursing home
or you have a relative that's
in a nursing home, and there's
no family visiting you,
no friends, you're
kind of waiting
for your next med or next meal.
It's kind of a
recipe for decline.
So we really want to bring the
community back into facilities.
We want to connect our
elders, whether they're
in a health care setting,
or they're at home
with their own music.
TONI THOMPSON: So you
may or may not know,
but Google has a very
strong volunteer policy,
where they give
us the opportunity
to volunteer on our
own terms, basically.
If I find a nonprofit that
I'd like to do some work for,
I can do that.
And Google will actually
subsidize my time,
as well as make a donation.
So talk to me about
how volunteers
fit into all of this.
DAN COHEN: So volunteers
are really important.
I mean, every day we're getting
people from around the country.
And I didn't mention
Canada, which
has a very large implementation
of Music and Memory.
They can get involved in
visiting the nursing home
or visiting a
hospice or a hospital
and helping them set up
their iTunes library.
They can help them get donations
from the community of devices
or money to buy the music.
The best thing is when
they really go one to one
and sit with individuals
who are, again,
they're sitting there alone.
And to have that
one-to-one time,
we have students at
universities and high schools
that go in all over the US.
And they're spending
that time with people,
which is really valuable.
And it's not only great for
the person who is elder.
It turns out it's great
for the youth as well.
They feel, wow, they got
to light up this person.
And this is the best
thing I've done.
You know?
That really gives them value and
helps build their confidence.
And so it's a big win.
So we're working very hard.
We have hundreds of high schools
and colleges that are involved.
In Wisconsin, we have
a special program
where we're connecting
37 high schools
and colleges with
37 nursing homes
as a template for the nation.
And we're going to
be rolling that out.
It already is happening.
Nursing homes and
schools don't really
have protocols for
this kind of stuff.
Everybody's doing
their own thing.
And so we're really
finalizing those protocols.
TONI THOMPSON: That's great.
And then that will
be distributed
to whoever wants it?
DAN COHEN: And then
it'll be distributed.
All the other states we have
made this public policy.
They're just going
to layer it in.
TONI THOMPSON: That's fantastic.
DAN COHEN: And that's how
we'll get tens of thousands
of schools and millions
of students involved.
TONI THOMPSON: So
do you find students
are from all walks
of life, so to speak,
different disciplines,
different reasons, and they're
attracted to the program?
DAN COHEN: Yes.
I mean, sometimes people have
had a family member who maybe
currently has Alzheimer's
or is in a nursing home,
or has other physical issues.
Or it could be just somebody
that wants to help out.
I mean, it's a wide
range of things, I think,
that draw people to it.
Or somebody has a
relative who has past.
And they'd like
to give back-- oh,
I wish I had this for my
grandma or my grandma--
and want to get in and
do something around this.
TONI THOMPSON: That
is so wonderful.
So not to leave you out,
Michael, what I'd like to do
is have you talk a little bit
about how the film came to be.
And where was that
happening, in your process?
And we'll switch over
to Michael a little bit.
MICHAEL ROSSATO
BENNETT: All right.
So I'm a filmmaker.
And I made a series of
short films for a nonprofit.
So a friend of mine
worked at the nonprofit.
And she called me
up and she said,
that this nonprofit--
this was back before.
I think you were
only in a couple
of nursing homes at the time,
maybe three or four, right?
DAN COHEN: I'll have to
look back and see how many.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
Can't remember?
I think he was in
about three or four.
DAN COHEN: Seven or eight.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
OK, seven or eight.
DAN COHEN: The ones listed
on the bottom of the movie.
TONI THOMPSON: Cool.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT: OK.
So anyway, I was just given a
job, to go and shoot something.
And I don't know if you've ever
been in a large public nursing
home.
But for somebody that's never
been in a place like that,
it's really overwhelming.
I mean, sometimes--
not all, but many--
like entering a layer of
"Dante's Inferno", if you will.
I mean, I remember the
first day I came there.
And I walked through this sort
of gauntlet of about 100 people
sitting against the wall
in wheelchairs, like this.
And one guy was going like this.
And I just wanted to run.
And it was very, very sad.
And something like
what's the statistic?
50% of nursing home residents
don't get any visitors.
And some of them are
there for, like, 10 years.
So it's a place of
loneliness, often.
There are some
beautiful facilities.
And actually, the
Music and Memory
has done a great job of
giving people in nursing homes
a tool so that they can connect,
instead of just be in a very
challenged care-giving role.
Anyway, I mean, Henry is really
the spark of this whole story.
Henry was put in front of me.
And I literally had no
idea what to expect.
And Dan had some music for him.
I think was Cab Calloway,
and some gospel music.
And I watched this man,
who a few minutes before
had been like this.
And with the music
on him, I watched
his entire being, like, wake up.
It was like somebody
plugged him in.
And something sprang
alive inside of him.
And I think we all
know that feeling.
Right?
That's just like when
we're on fire and alive.
And it freaked me out, in a way.
I mean, I started to cry.
I had tears in my eyes.
Because this was a
person who was gone.
And then we just gave him music.
And it went deep into his
mind and into his heart
and his memory and his body, and
his movement, and everything.
And he came alive.
Right?
And I think that all of us, deep
down inside, we want to live.
We want to live
sometimes more than we're
given the chance to live.
That's why I decided I
wanted to make this film.
Because if we could bring this
kind of life to these people,
right?
And then, it brought
so much life to me.
And I don't know if you've
seen the video with Henry?
TONI THOMPSON: Yes, I have.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
Yeah, OK.
You know, the man that came
out of that shell was a poet.
And he had a beautiful voice.
And he had a whole life.
And I got to feel it.
And this is one of the
most amazing things
that this work has taught me.
It is that people
with dementia actually
have something to teach us.
We think of them.
Our whole health care dynamic
is doing to or doing for.
Especially with
people with dementia.
The idea that we could do with
them is a totally novel idea.
And that's what music gives
you the possibility to do.
It gives you the
possibility to connect
on a very human, emotional, and
primal level with another human
being.
I told you a story a little
bit earlier about last week.
I was in a nursing
home, actually,
a Music and Memory facility
down in North Carolina.
And there was this
woman, full-on dementia.
And we gave her her music
and she started singing.
It was this Italian song,
like, by Jay and the Americans,
called Casa something or other.
Does anybody know?
She started singing.
And I started singing with her.
And she just looked
into my eyes.
And she knew that she
didn't really know me.
Like, she knew I wasn't
part of her life.
But her eyes just
poured into me.
And we sang together.
And I swear to God,
I have never-- I
felt like I was in a love story.
You know what I mean?
I felt like I was
in a love story.
I have never had
that experience.
I couldn't have that with you.
You know?
The thing about these minds
is that they've lost so much.
But what's left is basically
our deepest emotional being.
Some scientists call
it the embodied mind.
It's what we've inherited
from dogs and whales.
And our bodies, our emotions
are pretty much the same
as the emotions of
dogs and other animals.
That's why we can identify
with them so much.
You love your dog.
Right?
TONI THOMPSON: I don't have one.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
You don't have one?
TONI THOMPSON: I do.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
You have a dog?
TONI THOMPSON: Yeah, sure.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
You love your dog
because they are so pure.
And they touch a really pure
and elemental place in you.
And this is really what I
love about this whole journey,
is what there is to learn
about ourselves and each other,
and about the way we can
connect with each other.
I mean, that's what
happened with the film.
Why did a film about nursing
homes and dementia and aging,
why did that win Sundance?
Why did the Henry clip go viral?
Because there's something in
these people that literally,
I had never seen
before in my life.
And I really don't
think we, as a culture,
even have a word for it.
There's some kind of thing that
these people have to teach us.
And that's what
fascinated me, and why
I kept going for three years.
TONI THOMPSON: Yeah.
Your passion really
shows in the film.
And I hope all of you, who
are getting DVDs of this film,
will take a chance to watch it.
And you'll find it really,
really life affirming, and just
so pleasurable, to
see what is possible.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT: I
call it the only good-news film
ever made about dementia.
TONI THOMPSON: Oh my gosh.
That's very apt.
So tell me a little bit about
the Sundance experience.
How did that happen?
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
Oh my god.
That was incredible.
Like, you got to understand.
Like, I literally
didn't think anybody
would want to see this film.
TONI THOMPSON: Seriously?
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT: Yeah.
I mean, our culture isn't
that interested in aging.
It's not interested.
We take our elders that are too
much trouble to take care of
and we put them away, basically.
We put them out of
sight and out of mind.
Here we are at Google,
the absolute ground
zero for productive
young people.
Right?
You know?
There's no old people here.
I mean, I'm sure
there are, actually.
There's me.
TONI THOMPSON:
You'd be surprised.
MICHAEL ROSSATO BENNETT:
Wait, did I hear anything?
TONI THOMPSON: It's true.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
So anyway, I
didn't think anybody
would see it.
And I didn't even put it in.
I didn't submit to Sundance.
Because I was so broke
from making the film
that I said to my
wife, it's $100.
They're never going to
want to see this film.
Because it's about old people.
And they only want films
about young people and guns.
That was my thinking.
TONI THOMPSON: Whoa.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT: Anyway,
but my wife made me do it.
And it was a long
story about it.
I literally got it
into the mailbox
at literally the
last possible minute.
I mean, literally,
the doors were
shutting at the 34th Street
post office, when I dove
through them and I put it in.
And then Sundance
called and said,
that 12,000 films
had been submitted.
And they picked 16
for competition.
And one was ours.
And that was literally the
most amazing moment of my life.
And then when we won
the Audience Award,
that was just beyond belief.
And it's allowed
so much to happen.
It's brought international
attention to Dan and his work.
TONI THOMPSON: Wonderful.
MICHAEL ROSSATO
BENNETT: You know?
You don't know how many people
have come up to both of us
and said, oh my god, if
only I'd thought about this.
I'm a composer, and
my mom plays violin.
And if only I'd thought
to bring her her music.
And when we started this,
nobody thought, wow,
let's give people who
are dying their music.
Oh, let's give people who
have dementia their music.
Literally, it just
didn't hit their brains.
And now I think that
honestly, in the culture,
that there's been a shift.
And we had some small
part to play in that.
People now, it's
common human knowledge.
I think.
Maybe I'm wrong.
I'd love to know what
your audience thinks.
But I think it's common
human knowledge now
that wait, music is important.
It can bring back memories
in people with dementia.
It holds a place in us
that we should investigate.
Do you think people
know that, Dan?
DAN COHEN: Oh yeah.
Much more.
So Henry video, which has
passed 13 million views now,
that was hugely helpful.
The film itself, again,
many people have seen it.
But the media coverage has been
so generous around all of this.
Again, they don't have
good news stories to tell.
So oh, here's some good
news about old people
who are dying with dementia or
old people in nursing homes.
And so I would like to say,
that when it comes Thanksgiving
time, and everybody's
around the table,
somebody's is going to say
about their grandma, who's
got dementia, oh, well who's
setting up her playlist?
Who's getting her her music?
So it's just that common.
So but still building, so you
don't have to wait for somebody
to have the light turn on.
So we're getting there.
It's still a process.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT: Right.
TONI THOMPSON: Yeah.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
And about that idea,
so one of my dreams was a little
population illustration here.
This is the population pyramid
of human age in human history.
Over the last
400,000 years, we've
had very few elders
on top, and lots
of young people on the bottom.
OK?
TONI THOMPSON: Sure.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
Right now, it looks like this.
In Japan, it looks like this.
By about 2050, it's
going to look like this.
OK?
This is something absolutely
new in human history.
A one-to-one relationship
between the very young
and the very old.
This is earth shattering
in terms of how
it will affect our culture.
How will it affect
our government?
This is big stuff.
And right now, we have a
generation of young people
who, they're not
raised with the old.
For most of human history,
the Google of the world
was the old people.
The old people were the
carriers of the history,
of the how to survive.
Right now, any time we
need to survive, we Google.
Right?
But how do we create these
connections and preserve them?
There's real wisdom.
Wisdom is not, like, looking up
stuff and knowing your family
history.
Wisdom is how do you
get through life?
What's important?
What does it take to
live a satisfying life?
And any older person
will tell you this.
They probably wouldn't trade.
They'd love to be 20.
But they don't want
their 20-year-old self.
Because they've learned so much.
Right?
What about you?
TONI THOMPSON: Sure, absolutely.
What about me?
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
Would you
like to be 20 years
old, if you had to be
that 20-year-old mind as well?
TONI THOMPSON: No, I'd
want to bring along
my experience, of course.
MICHAEL ROSSATO
BENNETT: Exactly.
And so that's really what
I'm so interested in,
is this way of
creating connections
between the old and the young.
And to really make
it-- you know what?
What started this whole thing
was you were talking about Dan
said, on Thanksgiving,
how do you
find the playlist
for your elder?
And so I made an app.
It's about 99% done.
It's at memorydetective.com.
And what I was trying to
do is create something
that would let
young people-- just
by asking a series
of questions--
find all of the songs that
their grandma or their dad
or somebody would want to find.
And we're doing it with Spotify.
And it's a great way
to spend some time
with your grandma or your dad.
And so I encourage anybody
who's interested in going
on a musical journey, to
go there and try and find
some music for
somebody that you love.
TONI THOMPSON: Yeah.
That sounds like a great idea.
How about you, Dan?
I know that you've continued
to grow the Music and Memory
program.
What kind of
outreach do you have
for people who are caring
for an elder person at home?
DAN COHEN: Our website,
musicandmemory.org.
I mean, we have resources.
They can download a PDF, how to
create a personalized playlist
for a loved one at home.
It's pretty simple, yes.
And it facilitates
that communication.
And here are the steps.
And it's readily available.
We talk about how
people can volunteer.
Or we talk about how they
can raise money, do an iPod
drive, whatever,
how people can help
be an ambassador in
their communities to help
bring health care organizations
on board, all of those things.
TONI THOMPSON: That's fantastic.
I was just taking
a look at our Dory,
which has a question
from one of the Googlers.
It says, can special
needs kids be
helped with personalized music?
Do either of you have
an opinion about that?
DAN COHEN: Well, I think it's a
matter of what's going on now.
Special Ed is all over the
music already for the kids
who are on the spectrum.
TONI THOMPSON: In a similar way?
DAN COHEN: Well, not in
remembering, let's say.
I know that number
one, there are
nursing homes that have kids
that are chronically ill.
And they live there.
And the number one request
that the people who
run these homes have
told me is the kids
want their own devices,
whatever it is.
And you'd think they'd
have them automatically.
So yes, there's a lot of music.
People come in.
And the staff plays
a lot of music.
But again, it's that
have having your own,
the way we have our own.
I don't think we've
gotten there yet.
So the profession is very
attentive to the young.
So yes, Special Ed, and classes.
And the kids have
their devices that
are helping them communicate,
assistive communicative devices
for people who
can't communicate.
Maybe just on their tablet,
it just helps them speak.
But a lot of that stuff,
that works for the young.
It is not even thought
of for the elders.
So we can apply that.
You just can't take
the apps and such,
from people who are young,
and bring them over.
Because the subject
matter is for kids.
So even though somebody
might have dementia,
they know if you're
talking about kid stuff.
A lot of stuff, the
software, the content,
has to be re-papered, whatever.
TONI THOMPSON: Yeah, repurposed.
DAN COHEN: But in
terms of content,
and the ability to help
people who can't speak,
people who have
had a stroke, well,
maybe they can do it with
an app and help them speak,
even though they can't.
Some people who can't
speak, they can sing a song.
And sometimes they'll
sing the words.
They'll sing a song and
put the words to an action
that they need to do.
And it's to help
them communicate.
And so the stroke is really
a very interesting kind
of usage of music as well.
So there are a lot
of opportunities.
We just need to have more, I
think, programming attention
for elders.
Here we have this Baby
Boomer generation out there.
And many of us now, we're going
to bring our devices with us
wherever we go.
But there's this gap.
If we look at the
over 50, I mean,
everything with
all the streaming,
and all that discussion
in the media,
and all the hype
around streaming,
well, I think we're forgetting.
If somebody were
to do a survey--
and I've found nobody that's
captured the metrics on this--
for people over 50, how many
have access to their own music,
whether they've downloaded the
songs, or they're streaming?
And I think that number's
going to be under 10%.
And so you have
this massive cohort
of folks who have no music,
no help, and everything's
moving along way past them.
And we have to whoa, slow down.
So for the next 20
years or 30 years,
there's going to be
a group of people
that are going to
need assistance
in getting what will help them.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
Yeah, treat streaming
is a wonderful solution.
But I mean, most of the people
with dementia live at home.
And there's a lot that
live in nursing homes.
And a lot of the nursing
homes don't have wireless.
They have wireless in one room.
But in their rooms, they
don't have wireless.
So the streaming solution
just doesn't work that well.
But about people
with special needs,
I was shooting a
kid with autism, who
was just all over the place.
He was an Energizer Bunny,
just running around the room.
And then the woman came in.
She started to just
play some music.
And this kid just stopped.
Like, the Energizer
Bunny just stopped.
And yes, music can help
kids with special needs.
And it is being used a lot.
We're the only species
that actually does music.
I mean, there's some argument.
There's a lot of
communication, a lot
of sound in the natural world.
But music-- melodic,
creative melodic thing-- it
might just be limited
to human beings.
And it's actually been
integrated into our DNA.
A primate will not
respond to a beat.
But a baby child will.
So you're hitting this very
deep part of our brains
in our bodies.
And special needs kids
really respond to that.
It's a tremendous tool.
TONI THOMPSON: Yeah,
I'm sure we're all
going to be really surprised
at some of the work that
is coming out of this and coming
out of new efforts in research
and so forth.
If anyone would like
to ask a question here,
we do have microphones.
So please feel free to come up.
And I just want to hit one
more point with you, Dan.
What are you focused on today?
This has been a
great program, and I
know you're working to get
it going on in other places.
But are you thinking
in new directions yet?
DAN COHEN: So we
definitely want to bring
in all this tablet technology.
OK?
Because it turns
out that tablets
can be used for people
who have dementia.
Nobody thinks of that.
Everybody knows "Angry Birds".
But they don't know that there
are lots of Alzheimer's apps.
Either with those
names, if you use that
as a key word, or things that
don't have that as a key word
but are still good--
brain fitness,
relaxation, just games,
solitaire, blackjack.
My father-in-law was
always with the blackjack,
we played, or bowling.
He was a bowler.
But this is how he bowled now.
Right?
So all that stuff
helps people reconnect.
And again, it's done
with someone else.
You're not just saying,
here's your tablet.
We'll see you later.
For a lot of people it
becomes a point of connection.
So often we visit people
in facilities or at home.
And well, what do we do?
What do we say?
We kind of shrink from it
and can't wait to get out.
But when you have
something in common,
that you can
communicate on, then it
facilitates communication
and relationship.
And everybody feels better.
Actually, when
people get visited
in any kind of health
care residential facility,
music, maybe you listen
to it for an hour.
And that calmness, even
when the person leaves,
just keeps going for
the rest of the day.
TONI THOMPSON: Really?
DAN COHEN: And so I don't
think it matters so much what
the activity is, whether
it's music or just being
together and doing something
with someone that is fun.
TONI THOMPSON: It's
real stimulation.
DAN COHEN: Well, it has a
more-than-we'd-expect kind
of outcome.
TONI THOMPSON: That's great.
So I see we have
a question here.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
I have a question
about how do you
personalize the music for
the demand, for the person?
Because you say it's not
hey, here's the music,
and everybody gets that.
Right?
So you buy one music
and give it to everyone.
But then now, you have
to personalize music
to every person.
So are you going to buy
music for each person?
But in general, that's
kind of a very specific
logistics-based question.
But one thing I
was wondering was
if I get that DVD
now and go home,
and give to my mother, who
is visiting from India,
she would say, what
kind of a culture
puts old people into nursing
homes in the first place?
TONI THOMPSON: Good point.
AUDIENCE: And so
the broader question
is are we really solving the
broader problem here as well?
DAN COHEN: Great question.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
So one very core
logistic, how do you
go around things?
If I were to do that
from the ground up,
do I start buying songs
and put into devices?
How do you know the
person who can't remember,
are they telling you what
type of music do they like?
DAN COHEN: So there are
different parts to that.
So number one, in terms of the
technology and the approach,
there are different
ways to do that.
In terms of identifying
someone's music,
if they're unable to
communicate with you,
now we have a challenge.
Right?
So we'll go to their families
or friends, or even staff
that have seen how
they react when
different live music comes in,
and tries to build that list.
And if there's no
family around to ask,
we'll have to do trial
and error and just
OK, they were born in this year.
We'll give them music between
when they were 10 or 20
or whatever, and
see what sticks.
What do they respond to?
What do they light up to?
And slowly build
the list that way.
In India-- you raise a great
question-- many countries,
it's take care of
your family at home.
But the concept is the same.
And it's just a
matter of applying it.
So when I speak to people from
India, it's really just again,
it's communicating through
the sort of the systems
that people will listen to.
And in nursing homes, we
already have a lot of music CDs.
So we use the music CDs.
We follow iTunes
terms and conditions.
Because it allows you to
download once and sync
to an unlimited
number of devices.
Windows Media Player doesn't
have that same allowance
in writing, that
anybody's told me.
So that's sort of the legal
protection for the nursing
homes, is that they follow that
terms and conditions of iTunes.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
I'd just
like to add something to that.
Your question, you said,
what kind of culture
puts their elders
in nursing homes?
That's a huge
question, and one that
really should be addressed.
And I think we have to change
the way we find our safety,
the way we live together.
We're going to have to
change that if we're going
to deal with global warming.
We're going to have
to do that if we
deal with the
extinction of species,
which we're doing tremendous
damage to the world with.
So you know, Dan's doing a
great job in nursing homes.
But I'm kind of
a problem solver.
And I was, like, well,
what about all the people
that live at home?
You know?
There's more people
that live at home.
And I was, like, OK.
How do you do that?
How do you create the
most bang for the buck?
And I was like, well, if
we could get the kids,
if we could get you
interested in finding
your mother or your
grandmother's music,
find your grandmother's playlist
before she gets dementia.
You know?
And let's throw that online.
That's what I wanted to do.
And how can we
change the culture?
How can we change the way
people think about our elders?
Well, we have to do
that in education.
So let's create a curriculum.
So we started the Alive
Inside Foundation,
to develop curriculum to
help young people rethink
the way they look at aging.
And we have to rethink
the way we look at aging.
We have to rethink the way we
connect to the natural world,
our place in it.
We have to rethink our
idea of what safety is.
Maybe even rethink work.
I mean, we're maybe
50 years from robots
replacing manual labor,
from AI replacing-- I mean,
I heard the other day that you
guys, with that Google-- that
Go program, you did something
that no one thought would
happen for another 10 years.
Apparently they just came
out with an AI call center
program that will put 250
million people out of work
worldwide.
So how are we going
to deal with that?
We're going to have
to shift massively.
And I personally feel that music
is like one of those things
that we can hold onto.
It's one of the things.
We'll argue about God.
We'll argue about philosophy.
But we won't argue about
the way music affects us.
It's a commonality.
It's deep in our
emotional system.
It tells us that we're
really all the same.
It's very emotional.
And so you know, I'm very
interested in those questions
you raised.
And they're very
great questions.
Thank you for bringing that up.
TONI THOMPSON: Thank you.
And thank you both, for coming
to Talks at Google today.
You both are men with missions.
And you're going out and
doing great work in the world.
And we salute you.
DAN COHEN: Well,
thanks for having us.
It was great.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT:
Thank you for having us.
I didn't mention
aliveinside.org.
TONI THOMPSON: Oh, right.
MICHAEL ROSSATO-BENNETT: That's
the name of our foundation,
if anybody wants to help.
We also developed a
pair of headphones
for people with dementia at home
that is really, really cheap.
Because there are so many
poor people out there.
So we wanted to
create something that
would be really, really cheap.
So you could give it away.
TONI THOMPSON: So kind of
the DIY maker modality there.
It's, like, get the headphones.
Do this.
You're done.
That's great.
DAN COHEN: So when
people see the film,
and they want to help, so
The Alive Inside Foundation
is the filmmaker.
Michael did a fantastic
job on the film.
Music and Memory, the film
was about Music and Memory,
and our implementation
all over the country.
And we're looking for
the public to join us
at musicandmemory.org.
TONI THOMPSON: That's great.
Thank you so much.
And thank you all for attending.
[APPLAUSE]